io non so se devo essere preoccupato
dalla musica ma che minchia di
soundtrack è questa vabbè belle a tutti
ragazzi e benvenute questo nuovo io sono
file e risorse a she wolf che non ho
capito niente però mi piace che si sente
questo mi sento un po beppe vessicchio
proprio allora e non so la cosa bella è
che non sono neanche co sto giocando
proprio pagato 3 euro mai allora
movimento crouch open menu dire che ci
siamo
lei non c'è un piede enorme che mi è
entrato in casa ok tutto bene ragazzi no
perché mi sembra che ci siano dei funghi
o una puntata in un incantevole dove c'è
il piede di giustino comunque adesso
faccio chiede di mezzo piede schifoso in
casa devi muoverti a pulirmi va bene le
crew questo mi servirà tantissimo al
picco nei tool che schifo la cava che
qualche gioco è ma che gioco è già prima
cosa sta montando qualcosa stava cos'è
io ho pagato 3 euro sta roba santo iddio
mi serve un'altra roba
ecco tipo questo potrebbe aver senso
serve a li faccio esplodere con i pop
corn il piace capire tutto contento le
ripetute lo capo con la voce nicolò
contento
potevo stare quest'opera per fare questi
se non esplodono che schifo mi viene da
vomitare è veramente il gioco più
vomitevole che abbia mai fatto nella mia
vita prova beh devo prendere
qualcos'altro che non so cosa sia eccola
qua per fare per scacciare le morse che
sei la prima di tutto dovrà elevare i
funghi se permetti che schifo ragazzi
sono stati 3 euro più buttati dalla mia
vita a chi se frega perché c'è un piede
norme della stazza ma che mi servirebbe
comunque di nuovo il piccone se potesse
posto perché
quella roba lì ci sono ancora delle robe
che posso levare effettivamente però non
so dove l'ho lasciato il piccone dove
l'altra roba è fratello non so dove
trovare così per le parti funghi pensate
questo mese col piccone mi serve perché
anche quasi lista delle robe che non ho
colto bene devo trovare il caja unghie e
il leva pugni allora il taglia unghie
l'ho trovato il leva funghi non ho idea
di dove sia ma vabbè allora variabile un
modo decente permetto praga che schifo
devo aprire un salone di bellezza al
giorno mi sa che questa cosa è la cosa
più schifosa che abbia mai fatto in
tutta la mia vita
mancano i funghi immagino che sia quale
attrezzo per levarli anche se no non è
questo attrezzo perfetto ho trovato
aspetto sbagliato c'è una vasca volta la
mostra volta occhi aperti tra giove
ok c'è un'altra mosca didietro forcole
voglio dovere acchiappamosche dovrei
avercela fatta manca solo una mosca che
però non so dove la chiappa mosca non so
dove sia la chiappa mosca ragazzino
lasciato in bagno
ecco c'è solo le mosche rimasta solo una
da è da meno cuore a cuore parevano
moriva frate non morivano provato
proprio duemila volte
ok
dai non sono riuscito per una mosca
vince ma veramente ma io non ci voglio
che per una mosca a ragazzi se proverete
di provvedimentali d'aver gratuito con
il genere prof
ormai siamo qua giochiamolo che vedevo
di leviamo i funghi dunque veramente
possiamo perso per una mosca una c'era
una mosca
non voglio crederci ti pare che son
riuscito a perdere per una volta mio dio
quanto fa ischio mai fatta risulti così
la gamma neanche veramente misura quello
che la puntata di leone cane fifone
faceva meno schifo come è possibile che
poi comunque secondo c'è tutta una
tattica per fare in fretta che io non
conosco roberto copiamo abbiamo anche
questo è un po come giocare for guys
alla fine perché devi prendere il tempo
giusto
in realtà potrebbe bruciare anche le
morte ma non fa niente quant'altro
questi non sono pop corn sono pezzi di
mais
quindi mi viene da vomitare solo a dirlo
ma spiegami ma anche a questo è la
mancano queste le mostre che però non ho
idea di dove si trovi la chiappa mosca
perché non me lo ricordo mai nella vita
togliti che già difficile saliti in
groppa concepivano c'erano altre robe
dai manca solo acchiappamosche veloce
non so dove sia non me lo ricordo mai
eccolo dai zitto
mancano solo e mor che fa muro ben due
mori ma dai ragazzi ma le corse sono
fastidiosissime non riesco a farle fuori
banco morendo non muoiono ma neanche se
ci sto fermo sopra o perfetto ne mancano
due o forse tre aspettano lo so 12
questa è l'ultima memoria purtroppo
all'anteprima
non sono per niente orgoglioso di tutto
questo però fa niente sì sì va bene
allora provate dal record negativo fare
un minuto e mezzo è un miracolo se
riesco e ci prova da solo una volta e
pur perché in come punteggio posso
migliorare tantissimo ma solo una volta
ci provo questa è veramente l'ultima
ovunque ragazzi veramente non posso
portare tutto questo contenuto
contenuti i nerd ma che è emersa questa
è la merda in confronto profuma questo è
veramente schifoso ho solo più minuto e
che è veramente assurdo perché sono mai
andato meglio prima ma fa niente
ok allora subito le moschee raja che
qualche sono la parte più difficile
qui senza farla subito ciasun tolta di
mezzo totale piedi porco demonio che
fastidio perfetto perfetto ma anche al 2
robe raga mancano le unghie e il piccone
forse riesco prima che finisca al minuto
sarebbe record per me forse riesco prima
che finisce al minuto aspetta aspetta e
scendi 1 2 3 4 e 5 nov ugas ne manca due
perfetto ma che ora però c'è
è veramente difficile non ci voglio
credere o perso no ragazzi lei non sono
anche che doveva chi ecco qua no ma
porca trovo perfetto un minuto ho
battuto il record di prima lor
vediamo quanto ho fatto ho battuto
record di pre non è male ho migliorato
di un pelo cioè praticamente per me per
arrivare primo in assoluto
devo fare un minuto e mezzo che non è
possibile quindi ragazzi volevo fare un
ringraziamento particolare a matt murphy
e julian francis in particolar modo a
giulia francis perché la musica è bella
per avere insieme ai ragazzi questo era
a she was show dopo gatto 3 euro che vi
farà a vomitare per le prossime due
settimane però questi esseri contenuti
che porto non lamenti se descrittivo nel
mio canale non rompete le chiedetevi
ancora dopo questo video e noi come
sempre ci veniamo allo pastorino bella
ragazza
[Musica]